today's classic interview is just a
personal favorite of mine since I'm in
Las Vegas why not do something that's
just fun and it is my interview with
Sharon Gilbert from November of 2014 she
is a so-called Bible biologist who said
that the Ebola induced end times were
proven by biblical time travel I don't
know how I could give a more precise
introduction than that so I won't let's
get to my interview with Sharon Gilbert
I'm joined today by Sharon Gilbert who's
a trained biologist and a Bible scholar
she believes the Ebola outbreak in West
Africa might might be a sign of an
inevitable global pandemic connected
possibly to the fourth Horsemen of the
Apocalypse and Sharon it's really great
to have you on because we've been
talking for several weeks now we've been
hearing from people ranging from Matthew
Hagee to Glenn Beck and others that
Ebola may be a sign of what they
describe colloquially as the end times
you seem to at least partially coincide
that this could be a possibility you
know I I think I do agree with that camp
I'm very honored to be included in that
company by the way I that what we are
seeing now is the very early stages of
what may eventually be a worldwide
pandemic as described in the book of
Revelation and talked to us about how
you decided that the Book of Revelations
and specifically what in it might be
connected with what you see happening
today well in the book of Revelation we
see in chapter 6 for different horsemen
who are sent out by God to begin the
final seven-year period of what we call
is called the Tribulation Period
oftentimes meaning but in in the Book of
Daniel Daniel is given a vision of
seventy weeks that occurs 69 of those
weeks and it's actually groups of seven
years 69 of those groups of seven years
occurred just prior to Christ's
triumphal entry into Jerusalem at that
point it stopped and we entered when
Christ arose what's now called the
church age and that's lasted about 2,000
years we need to get to that final
seven week sorry seven year period that
final week of the 70 weeks of Daniel is
prophecy and that's what we see in the
book of Revelation that sucked that
final the first year the first moment of
that seven-year tribulation period
begins when these riders are sent out
the first rider goes out and he's given
a crown he rides a white horse this is a
picture of the Antichrist he is there to
take peace from the world and it's only
logical that he's followed by the second
rider who is the one who rides a red
horse it's fiery red and he's given
authority to take peace from the earth
through war and the third rider is on a
black horse he carries the scales but
the word that's translated as scales
also can mean a yoke so it's it's an
oppressive sort of economic system that
rides out the soul so Sharon that's a
lot there so let's maybe pause there and
take it a piece at a time if we can it's
I really like this is good stuff for me
because I really like exploring what
people's kind of world view is and and
what they evaluate to be worthwhile
evidence for a particular belief so I'm
hearing two things in kind of your
explanation one is that you believe at
least somewhat literally the prophecies
that you've identified within the
scriptures and number two that correct
me if I'm wrong you believe that the
Bible is the literal and infallible Word
of God am I wrong about either of those
two assumes you are correct in both of
those so let's start with the second one
first if that makes any sense tell our
audience a little bit about why you've
you believe in other words that the
scriptures are the infallible and
literal Word of God why do you believe
that well I came to know Christ when I
was relatively young I was only about
nine years old when I actually made the
public affirmation of my belief in
Christ as my savior
okay I I as many teens I wandered off
when I got into high school and I I
began searching for my own answers and
during my 20s I continued to search for
those answers it was only in my 30s that
I became you know I returned to
reading the Bible getting back into a
daily Bible study and in my late 30s and
early 40s I went back to college and I
got my degree in molecular biology it's
actually a biology degree but at Indiana
University and with many large schools
you can't just say I want to study
biology you have because it's a huge
field yes excuse what part of biology
you want to study am i with cellular and
molecular biology did a lot of study on
genetics and some viruses and and I had
an amazing time I got to my graduate
program and I I while I was there and I
you I met my husband online so I believe
in in technology I believe in science
but the more I delved into the world of
the cell and the incredible way that DNA
is transcribed and replicated when I
looked at even below the molecular and
atomic level of the subatomic particles
particles and the the order that is
there it became clear to me that
everything that that the lord has told
us has to be true you either believe
that we arose by chance or you believe
that this incredibly ordered universe
was actually designed and you fly my
question may be a little bit different
though I don't mean to interrupt you but
let me see if I can reframe the question
a different way to really get at what
I'm trying to get you you've described
that the complexity and specificity with
which your science research that that
your science research kind of exposed to
you led you to believe in a higher power
but my question now it was a different
one though or maybe that's not what you
said but it certainly wasn't an answer
to my question which is how did you
decide that Christian scriptures are the
literal and infallible Word of God in
other words that's not there wasn't
evidence for that specifically in the
cell was there no that's true but what I
was getting to is how I came to truly
knowing as a scientist yeah that what I
was reading in Scripture what was that
God created us that's the beginning
point if you don't believe in creation
then there's no way that you can believe
that the scriptures in the Bible are
true right and that's probably
increasingly why most P
don't but I want to know why Sharon
Gilbert in other words does it say in
the Bible that God's Word that that it
is itself the infallible and literal
word of God in fact it does it says that
all scripture is available for teaching
and discernment we see that in first
Timothy but what hold on saying that the
Bible is available for teaching and
discernment where does that say that it
is the infallible and literal Word of
God
well what do you believe in I don't
believe that the Christian scriptures
are the infallible or literal Word of
God
well then I got that impression just
from the way your your question was but
I want to know why you believe that you
know it's very difficult as a believer
to to phrase in a way that makes sense
to a non-believer it's sort of putting
on a pair of glasses suddenly
spiritually and that pair of glasses
sharpens your vision and suddenly it's
why could I not believe in it so you're
saying it's difficult to articulate why
it is that you're chosen to believe that
it's difficult to articulate the
position of someone who is covered in
the blood of Jesus Christ I I place my
faith in the cross and because God said
that all scripture is available to us
and because from the first century down
that the Bible as we have it today has
been presented as the inerrant scripture
right and I either believe all of it or
I go through and I say well I can't
agree with this chair off this page I
can't agree with this chair off this
page but the part that disagreement I
have with you respectfully Sharon is
that it's been presented as the inerrant
Word of God by fundamentalist Christians
god never said this is the inerrant and
infallible Word of God that's not in the
Bible have you ever read it yes and I
haven't found that if it's in there tell
me where it is because all you said is
is that it says that it's available to
all but saying that that a text is
available doesn't mean that it's the
literal and infallible Word of God does
it tell me what books you do believe I
believe science books for example why do
you believe this because it's based on a
very specific and
fundamental scientific method that has
been built upon the shoulders of the of
we know exactly who built the structure
of that and it is a kind of cumulative
method it doesn't rely on believing that
any higher power that we can't identify
gave this information to anybody whose
word were taking that they wrote it down
and that has translated it properly I
mean that we're eliminating so many
variables when we look at a science book
mm-hmm well that that's I think how many
people would answer that question they
believed because of the scientific
method that what you find in science
books is 100% believable no but did I
said Sharon did I say that everything in
a science book is 100% believable I just
said that the method which is used is a
method that to me is a is more logical I
didn't say everything that has ever been
in a science book is accurate well you
did imply it
no I didn't imply it nor did I say it
but Sharon we have we have a limited
time left there was that second piece
that I wanted to ask you about which was
the prophecies of the sacred text let's
get past for a second whether we believe
or not that it's the infallible and
literally hours and hours trying to
agree to exactly that what platform
we're going to speak from yeah and we
probably wouldn't agree
so my question about the prophecies is
you you believe in in some of the
prophecies that you've identified in the
sacred texts I've believed in all of
them
well but there are so many that have
already been proven false so how do you
account which one okay so for example
first Corinthians 729 we see that Paul
expected that he and the Christians of
his time would see the second coming of
Christ
that didn't happen that was a prophecy
that did not happen there's 10 20 30 40
of these well I think you've
misinterpreted that he looked for it in
his lifetime we all look for it within
our lifetimes oh so you're saying that
it was just a prophecy that he was
hoping for but it wasn't a true prophecy
because retroactively Lia didn't no no
no no the Bride of Christ the church
that is a mystery which means that it is
something that is revealed over time oh
yeah well what about that's fine I mean
Sharon what about Matthew 16:28 word
Jesus clearly predicts that the Second
Coming will be during the lifetime of
the first century Christians that did
not happen that was Jesus read that text
to me and explained how that said that
verily I say unto you there be some
standing here which shall not taste of
death till they see the Son of man
coming into his kingdom that means those
who say hold on Sharon those who see me
now will not die until they see me back
here that's very clear the Apostle John
saw that that's what the book of
Revelation is he lived to see that John
saw the second coming of Christ yes he
did
so the second coming of Christ already
happened no no he went into the future
you might say he saw a vision he was
taken remember God speaks from a
position of that is outside our
space-time continuum I see I did not I
apologize I did not realize that he had
traveled and spoken retroactively Lee
from the future I had never heard that
before
well he was taken up in a vision and he
was shown visions of the future so he
saw it all right we've been speaking
with Sharon Gilbert I can't think of a
better note on which we can leave it
there so to speak I apologize we didn't
have more time to dig into the Ebola
specifically but I think that this
interview has been just a fascinating
experience for our audience and I can't
thank you enough thank you very much